youn l'épisode du cpe les mains en l'air
vous avez vu voilà c'est ce changement
qui elle sur la chaîne depuis ces deux
dernières années aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec un père de deux petites
filles plus mignonne l'une que l'autre
oh oui des filles qui en grandissant
vont beaucoup plaire au jeune homme au
nom à aa
non sincèrement j'espère qu'ils vont
être moche plus tard late la hantise de
tout papa vous l'aurez deviné c'est
qu'un joueur najet avec nous comment ça
va jan écoute ça va très très bien et en
tant que père de famille
je pense que pour une fois un c'est un
jeu qui met totalement dédié absolument
que ça va me faire plaisir
absolument parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
sur plusieurs dali aujourd'hui on va
jouer un bébé et son père le bébé peut
faire plein de bêtises s'opère
d'empêcher vous connaissez déjà le
principe voilà je vais commencer à jouer
le petit bébé et tu devras me met la
poudre blanche sur les fesses si je
parle pas de cocaïne le talc
bien sûr ça commence jan o quoi c'est
qu'on soit en finale qu'on a fait on
aura atteint donc laisser abuser ou g
spawn tu sais pas où j'ai spot pour moi
il a pas s'accroupir à chaque fois je
m'en bats les sexes et aux problèmes
père au perche est en train de voir que
la boisson mon pote c'est tellement bon
alors il était à ces derniers dans la
cuisson à ces délicieux mais ce qu'il
est il est nulle part laissons les gages
laisse moi tranquille papa je suis caché
bébé lui lui tu fais quoi loger alors
oui ce qu'il ne trouvera pas papa je
trouverai pas non à avatar c'est ça oui
je te frappe tu perdais bien papa en
fait je vous frapperai j'ai à te frapper
je te jure pourquoi on au plafond ou pas
pas beaucoup de bas parce que papa il
marche au plafond tout simplement je
savais très bien que tu marches on
craque turelet saberi chartres amour
aimer papa je vais tuer par contre il
reste 15 points 8 5 points de vie papa
et voilà j'ai tué le père attend avec
sur l'écran tôt le mon père 35is
épilepsie cette fois et je vais jouer le
papa pourtant je me suis rasé ont dirigé
12 ans et demi et tu sais que je fais
très bien
le cri du bébé vas-y fais attention au
bal à temps mais ça abusé sa mosaïque
d'art mais ça tu veux un secteur bouche
voilà maintenant on arrête tout là on
sait on arrête de tourner c'est pas
possible j'ai vu pratiquer sébastien de
monter sur france 2 plus grand cabaret
du monde mon gars à moi à moi avons
choisi
ouais c'est pas bon pour un canard
mourens est bien titulaire et au nez
était bon
la à john cena mon gars comme toi la
prise électrique arrête [ __ ] c'est
quoi les petits des titans culte des
mecs comme toi t'es trompé avec tesco
fabrique non on les fout dans le petit
barbecue office de fuck you grille tu
grille
je sais que t'as pas le bébé dans les
mains là bas alors c'est pas toi j'ai
dans les mains qui s'est passé dans le
salon la dubai al anon les mecs tu
déconne mais gros tu viens de konoha tu
sais pas des clones mais t'es où vas tu
crois pas que tu as tes pieds devant toi
mais tu viens de partir de maintenant à
l'instant j'ai gagné on s'offre aux yeux
tassé de me rendre confus ouais mais
calme ici du bas de la nuque en [ __ ]
j'ai spawn dans le meilleur endroit du
monde de cuisine peut-être avoir la
charge en tant que j'arrive élus
arrêtent
est ce que bébé l'élu les dans le
placard tc paris le congrès là et là je
voulais chanter je suis comme toi on
partage un moment on partage un moment
regarde par calme c'est bon partageons
le haut biveau tout ça non t'es où t'es
il s'est barré je suis nulle part pas
pas attendu le père à merde
le pen a trahi le nord tu retournes dans
ton lit parce que là tu as été non non
non mais non
baby weeds pourquoi j'ai gagné je
t'explique parce que c'est quand même à
ton bébé de 3 mois t'expliquer pourquoi
tout juste de tomber bébé mort tu ne vas
trouver les médicaments nécessaires mais
maintenait en vie
cramé je savais pas qui fait que je
trouve ça tes pairs ou tepa perds tu te
dois de le savoir
et ce qui est drôle c'est que je sais
que t'as pas commencé dans la chambre
donc je sais pertinemment que tu as
commencé dans la cuisine et commencera
cuisine non j'espère que dans la cuisine
via un piano mais non mais oui petit
mais je te vois je passe sur l'écran
vient pas égale un papa comment ça tu
veux non j'étais un câlin jette avec
alain thébault voilà je fais chauffer la
choix des choix non arrête [ __ ] ça
lâchait beaucoup cherché à aller où
exactement
nulle part à 20 h c'est une cuve à
l'essai dans la piscine
tiens on là je vois plus rien là je ne
peux plus bouger
je ne peux plus bouger abbas était en
train de mourir
festor a entendu du bruit à l'étagé me
trouve un vieux tu trouveras jamais été
engagée peut-être je suis enfin c'est de
partir avec la voiture papa aimé lui oui
quoi quoi quoi rien n'y a rien là bas je
suis passé par une trappe j'ai attiré à
tes pieds boîte à piéger les conduit tu
veux t'amuser joue avec le bidon
d'essence car il est là at-elle il me
donne des gages de vie naissance en
tongs à quoi je puisse prendre là
pourquoi tu peux te prendrai ce que je
suis tout me le suis tout ouïe le du
coup je veux plus attraper à voilà voilà
j'avais sorti une théorie tu l'a
contrait j'ai mis de l'essence
impétueuse j'avais oublié ça papa je
suis en train d'écrire une lettre disant
que c'est toi qui m'as tué avant de
mourir pour ça ça me ferait bien chier
ça ouais je sais pas moi les piles help
appartient jour-là que 44% à temps je
t'ordonne de neuquen était venue ou pas
non car on toujours que 44 % c'est pas
bon ça ah bah si tu marches
si tu approches de saute dans l'eau
situe après je saute dans l'eau jusqu'à
demain je suis pas prendre tu peux
prendre pas pas plus lui et l'ont
tellement pas plus elle attend des
jumeaux l'exploit si je me dépêche toi
papa j'arrive j'arrive n'aura pas le
temps de mourir parce que j'ai déjà les
pilules moi je suis un vrai papa mais
voilà allez je te lance roquettes a
atterri bien à l'étroit si cela je suis
en tort de la map
mais je vole pas été dans ma main je
suis dans l'espace mais alors qu'ils
devaient chiens dans les mains auquel
j'ai mis un cadenas autour du cou je ne
sais pas mais c'est pas moi je suis dans
l'espace
j'ai gagné mon fils est né dans l'espace
mais il est en vie un pas sur la barre
trouver des pilules je viens de voir des
choses mauvaises pour la santé papa je
suis dans la douche fleurance parce que
ça brûle puisque thé car tu vas trop
posé sur le lit de papa tu va trier les
affaires oui j'adore le lit de papa
c'est l'amour tu as fait garçons oui
j'appelle ça mon plan de travail
voilà là je la joue très bien tu as
peut-être une nintendo 3ds là dedans ah
non qu'est-ce que tu as comme amant
s'ennuie quand papa est pas là puisque
je suis quelques pas et étaient juste là
ouais j'ai passé dans un conduit
je suis mère de sam fisher bâtard j'ai
mangé le cac a du chien pas paoli chat
chien c'est pas vrai en copa je suis
mort mais j'arrivais bon [ __ ] faut
vraiment jeté en scène comment être un
bon père ian attend bouge pas tiens joue
avec sa voix l'a eu
pourquoi tu joues pas avec le jouer mais
toi face à moi qu'est ce qu'ils
apprennent avec ma position yade en fait
t'es genou son niveau de tes épaules ça
va là c'est mieux c'est différent papa
je veux une glace d'accord fiston
j'arrive je te donne ça tiens tiens tu
fais comme ça et obtint une bonne glace
pilée fiston au nom au nom
je veux pas te faire peur les veinures
il ya un singe dans le salon quoi qu'il
en soit pas par ga temps je te mettre à
côté de lui là sur le canapé mais qu'est
ce qu'il fout là bien singe est ici ou
city ouistiti voilà c'est ouistiti faut
aimer comment t'as fait manger de tout
éloge c'est de faire sa ba il faut
mettre cinq médailles dans la prise yann
à moi je pensais que lui et toi ça
suffisait bah non
ah ben c'est comme en vrai en faible
hausse était en hausse était moins une
terre tu passeras le reste de ta vie
dans ce placard avec la loi parce que je
suis pas close à plat car tu crois tu
m'as la loi bah ouais bah non la preuve
regarde sa beauté dans la cuisine la
porte ouverte à un possible t1 visibles
les 30 mars à la maison est hantée
pistolet à bbb lui pique
n'était pas là mais ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à passer voir sa chaîne il
par écrit des vidéos ouais il apprend à
mettre des couches à bien que son enfant
c'est ma vie privée ça reste privé tu as
fait ta petite crise à la mi mars à la
salle athéna le projet vidéo portez vous
bien qu'à dubaï urines